so the story
is about the rise of david roland the
son of a scrap medal dealer from
south london who rose to become the
confidant
to prince andrew he'd acquired this
um this luxembourg bank caltv bank
and they proceeded to turn kalphing uh
luxembourg into what they now called
bank havoland
prince andrew had become some kind of a
roving ambassador
for the for the rolands you know with
their
unofficial door open at prince andrew
they kind of went around the world
hoovering up
clients um from among the ranks of the
world's sort of worst kleptocrats
and and criminals
i don't think anyone comes out well out
of this tale
prince andrew certainly does not come
out well
you have the queen's favorite son going
out
and basically being a glorified salesman
for this really quite dodgy bank
we thought it'd be absolutely
fascinating to start having an
uh a better more in-depth look at what
is bank have a land
who are the rolands and what is their
relationship
with prince andrew
[Music]
so derek roland had very humble
beginnings
he left school at 16. he's a short guy
barrel chestered he's got a kind of near
permanent
scowl on his face
he peppers his speech with uh
foul expletives he's a rough character
who's done very well for himself
by the 1990s he was well off enough
to set up a family office and this
family office was not
just handling his own money it was
almost like a shadow banking operation
they would provide finance loans to the
types of people who couldn't otherwise
get it but they were very wealthy
not many people in the uk would have
heard of him until probably about
late 2010s around that sort of time
when a lot of his stories started coming
about about his friendship with prince
andrew
so prince andrew is the second son
of the queen of uh of england
and he is by some some reports her
a favorite son he's never been in any
danger
of being any particularly close to
becoming king or anything like that you
know obviously his older brother charles
is going to be king
you know he didn't go to university he
went straight into the navy
he then became a pilot and by uh all
accounts
um so very bravely in the the falklands
wars there as a helicopter pilot
that's my helicopter flying over at the
moment i think this
is almost time i should go but never
mind somebody's telling me it's time to
go
but after that once he left the the
royal navy
in the 80s he seemed to have become a
bit of a um
a lost soul he he became a kind of
magnet
for for somewhat disreputable people
quite how prince andrew and david roland
got into a similar orbit
is not entirely clear all we do know is
that
they did we know that they've been
friends since at least 2005
one of the earliest photographs we have
of the two of them together is
andrew unveiling a larger-than-life
size statue of david roland on his
guernsey estate and they are an odd
pair obviously david roland is a sort of
working class boy
done good whereas andrew is a prince of
the realm who
you know was born into fabulous wealth
and you know
raised in palaces and castles
[Music]
as we go on air there are crisis talks
about how to stabilize the banking
system
what started in america last year has
now spread to every part of the world
what you had was in 2008 2009 you had
this banking crash
and if you had some money and you were
pretty sort of risk tolerant there was
an amazing opportunity there
and the roland seized it they absolutely
seized this opportunity
caltfing had been one of the big victims
of the financial crisis
it was this icelandic bank that went off
on this massive
lending spree and it all came to a
judging halt in 2008.
about 30 000 shareholders were in
crepeling when the bank collapsed
david roland came in and he bought
the luxembourg arm of of calvin bank
they were somewhat desperate to find a
buyer the best buyer before the rolands
turned up was um
the uh libyan um sovereign wealth fund
so there weren't a lot of takers for um
for bank cavalland
so that's why david roland managed to
get it
so cheek and they started to proceed to
turn
what the renamed now bank haveland into
this private banking business based in
luxembourg
and going after the world's wealthy as
private banks do
private banks are there to serve the
interests the wealth of
of wealthy people but it had
a slightly different business model to
most of them
so we find them going off in this
amazing
worldwide jaunt to to basically bank the
world's
dodgiest people you know we're talking
dictators we're talking
um uh scammers you know if you
had dodgy money the rolands were
seemingly interested in you
and there didn't really seem to be any
limits to who they'd go after
so for instance you'd see them go for
the leadership of azerbaijan which is
one of the world's most corrupt
countries on earth
[Music]
the roland's flew to azerbaijan
with prince andrew on their private jet
a number of times to meet
with president aliev and
his family prince andrew at the time was
a
trade ambassador for the uk so
he had tried to carve out this role for
himself and the government
had carved out this role for him as a
special trade envoy for the uk
ostensibly he was an ambassador for
british business
and with his royal title doors could be
open for him that wouldn't be open
to ordinary mortals
and the roland's looked to effectively
use this relationship this special um
place that prince andrew had to
basically get to people that they
wouldn't have
otherwise been able to you know remember
bank avalanche is a tiny tiny
institution you're only talking
probably about a billion or so of assets
so if you have this small business and
you want to get into
or close to people with lots of money
you need a special in
and it seemed like their special end was
prince andrew
they quickly build up a relationship
with aliev's family
you might not think that there's
anything wrong with dealing with
presidents of countries um
but at the time that the rolands were
visiting
with aliyev he had already been accused
by human rights groups of uh
torturing opposition politicians of
jailing journalists
of changing the constitution to make him
president for life leaked u.s diplomatic
cables
described him as a mafia hood who
ran azerbaijan in a manner of
sort of feudalism in in europe in the
middle ages
[Music]
both sides of the atlantic in recent
years there's been a big crackdown on
money laundering and that has made most
banks incredibly wary of who they take
on
as clients but the roland's were a bit
different
you know with their unofficial door open
at prince andrew they
kind of went around the world hoovering
up clients
um from among the ranks of the world's
sort of worst kleptocrats a sort of
prize example of that is kola aluko
he was a nigerian oil magnate who
came to the rolands in 2015
to get a 25 million euro loan
[Music]
now if if the owners had done a google
search on him at the time they would
have discovered that he um
he was already under investigation in
nigeria
for his part in a massive massive fraud
there involving bribery and corruption
and the
awarding of oil contracts but
they loaned him 25 million euros and
sure enough within days of that loan
being signed the nigerian former
nigerian oil minister
was arrested for her part in the fraud
and
the police started looking for
arguably the the pinnacle of um david
roland's social climb
was the 2018 wedding of
prince andrew's daughter eugenie
here you have a granddaughter of the
queen
marrying a on national television
at st george's chapel which is the
same place where prince harry and meghan
markle got married
and you have um all of the great and the
good of the country
are are going in there to be seated
to to witness this occasion to join
together this man and this woman
you know he had front row seats with his
wife they were in the aisle
sitting next to kate moss and there you
have
david roland in
less than six decades david roland had
ascended from being the son of a scrap
medal dealer to to
rubbing shoulders with with royalty but
already at that time the legal
noose was was tightening around
his bank
cola aluko had defaulted on
the 25 million euro loan that he owed to
tobaccoland
and that had led to the biggest
foreclosure in new york history on this
condo that he owned
and it became tabloid fodder and for the
first time
bank haveland were linked to this
central figure in one of nigeria's
biggest ever
frauds and that caught the attention
of the luxembourg regulators back home
who um took a look at bank avalon's
dealings with aluko and really didn't
like
what they found when they took a deeper
look
into bank cavallan's clients they
found that they were also banking
the daughters of president aliev and
other
prominent azerbaijanis and
they found that they'd done so with very
little due diligence
in terms of background checks into the
source
of their wealth
[Music]
it isn't much fun uh being prince andrew
these days um ever since photographs
emerged of him with his arm around the
waist of a young girl
in the entourage of jeffrey epstein
he has been somewhat toxic these days
he seldom leaves the confines of windsor
park where he lives
in his uh in a nice big house
[Music]
so the bank's old buccaneering ways are
um
very much behind it and what you have
is this agreement between the two sides
that bank have land will lower its risk
appetite
the problem you then have obviously is
that well if you're just a normal
private bank
trying to go after the same people
everyone else's why would you bank a
bank haveland right why wouldn't you go
to some other bigger place that has more
services
and the simple answer to that is you
would go to one of those places
most likely in which case bank have land
really doesn't have a purpose any longer
[Music]
you